-Performing her new song,
"Transparent Soul,"
featuring Travis Barker,
once again, here's Willow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-1, 2, 3, 4!
♪♪
-♪ I don't [bleep] know
if it's a lie or it's a fact ♪
♪ All your little fake friends
will sell your secrets
for some cash ♪
♪ Smile in my face, then put
your cig out on my back ♪
♪ If you ever see me, just get
to runnin' like The Flash ♪
♪ I knew a boy just like you ♪
♪ He's a snake, just like you ♪
♪ Such a fake, just like you ♪
♪ But I can see ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ I can see right through,
just so you know ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ I can see right through,
just so you know ♪
♪ I don't [bleep] know if
it's paradise or it's a trap ♪
♪ Yeah, they're treating me
like royalty,
but is it kissin' ass? ♪
♪ No one's brave enough to
take the fall right ♪
♪ But it's all your fault,
why you actin' like
it's all right? ♪
♪ I knew a girl just like you ♪
♪ She was vain, just like you ♪
♪ Such a pain, just like you ♪
♪ And everybody knows ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ I can see right through,
just so you know ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ I can see right through,
just so you know ♪
♪ It's clear to me now ♪
-♪ You're scared of me, wow ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ It's clear to me now ♪
♪ You're scared of me, wow ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪♪
-♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ I can see right through,
just so you know ♪
♪ Transparent soul ♪
♪ I can see right through,
just so you know ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]